du tabou existentialiste de 1952 au
théâtre de dix heures en 1962 le chemin
parcouru par pour réussir ou le même que
le vôtre celui de montmartre les a
conduits à une réussite exceptionnelle
et chaque soir monsieur snop sans
remporté un véritable petit triangle
nous recevons chaque soir ici à notre
tribune une personnalité étrangère qui
vient nous exposer ses vues sur le
délicat problème de la liberté
individuelle
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand honneur de
céder la parole à monsieur alexandre
josse ce cher monsieur chnops si vous
voulez bien si vous voulez vient
d'entrer je suis heureux de vous
accueillir ici je suis d'autant plus
qualifiés pour prendre la parole dans
votre tribune que j'ai quitté mon pays
et que je viens demander asile à la
france
eh bien écoutez cher monsieur voyez-vous
sans avoir consulté qui que ce soit je
puis vous dire moi d'ores et déjà que
cet asile
nous vous l'accordons et le grand choeur
croyez le bien je n'en attendais pas
moins et vous voilà vous pouvez être
rassurés
vous avez en quelque sorte choisi la
liberté alors j'ai selon la formule
usitée choisi la liberté mais j'ai
d'ailleurs l'impression qu'on peut hélas
de moins en moins vivre là bas
vous voulez dire qu'on ne peut plus
vivre du tout du tout du tout du tout
mais vous vous êtes échappée de russie
même où d'un pays satellites de suisse 2
je me suis échappée de suisse
écoutez là c'est la première fois que
j'entends dire ça ce ne sera pas la
dernière j'ai montré la voie d'autres
suivront
mais qu'est ce qui a motivé votre départ
de suisse la tyrannie du régime
helvétique fait surtout surtout à bompas
que le régime helvetica et tyrannique
pas c'est à dire que toutes les libertés
sont réduites à néant tout simplement
nous vivons en vase clos
prenons un exemple quelconque vous
voulez respirer là bas n'est ce pas eh
bien vous ne pouvez respirer que de
l'air suisse évidemment oui mais je
pensais à part ça qu'il existait une
grande liberté d'expression mon cher ami
liberté d'expression oui pour les gens
qui sont dans la ligne qui se contentent
de dormir de travail et de boire de
manger de se distraire à la rigueur mais
pour les autres les autres ceux qui
aspirent à autre chose alors pour ces
gens là c'est les to francs alors les
adultes bien entendu se résigne
mais il a jeunesse monsieur notre pauvre
jeunesse
mais c'est le problème de la jeunesse
évidemment la jeunesse la jeunesse est
imprimé voit un le mal actuel de la
jeunesse ne pénètre pas chez nous la
jeunesse est muselée mais aucune fureur
de vivre
aucun goût de la violence est cependant
monsieur cette jeunesse à la besoin de
s'extérioriser
elle a besoin de frapper d'un sommet de
tuer comme partout ailleurs
bah évidemment si on ne tue pas 20 ans
et pas cinquante qu'on le fera mais d'où
vient cette amortie au trille et d'où
vient cette mollesse à mon avis d'une
trop lourde hérédité de paix ça alors et
écoutez franchement entre nous on est
bien content on ne dépose pas les armes
pendant des siècles sans que la jeunesse
en soufre un jour ou l'autre allons
voyons une paix qui a fait un mal fou à
se payer à tous ses enfants mais
sûrement et puis alors chez nous vous
comprenez pas d'exemple pas de capitaine
pas de jeanne d'arc personne n'a jamais
bouter les anglais hors de suisse
ils n'ont jamais envahi la suisse non
plus faut dire d'accord mais on aurait
pu les provoquer ah c'est certain nous
n'avons jamais été regard avec la france
non est-ce que c'était bien nécessaire
merci quand même ne serait ce que pour
favoriser un rapprochement c'était
nécessaire ne vous croyez moi chez nous
il y à une invitation permanente à la
paix oui c'est la paix froide sont j'ai
songé que notre pays vient de subir
trois grandes paix mondiale monsieur en
sont des choses des choses auxquelles on
ne pense pas toujours mais évidemment
évidemment sont des choses qui comptent
t3 grande p3 grande paix en quoi ans
entend exactement prenez l'exemple de
mon grand père mon grand père a fait 71
14 18 39 et 45 63 3 p3p dans la vie d'un
homme ça compte ça compte quand même et
il est toujours de ce monde il a tenu le
coup il est toujours de ce monde où il
vient de s'engager dans la légion ajouté